leute herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
video ich hab meine letzte klausur
geschrieben hier am bodensee das heißt
ich dich jetzt ab alter scheiß auf den
fucking wehrleute ich gehe nach köln
morgen geht's in den urlaub und ich
denke dass die richtig richtig geil
deswegen mit in diesem blog lassen like
da lasten abo da
[Musik]
ich denke ich mal
guten morgen aus bad honnef gestern beim
marketing köln getan hat mein ganzes
volk seien gepackt und gegen kumpel
abholt die nord gefahren
mit dabei waren einzelne blogs unser
kumpel von mir in lucka studieren hier
drüben university und die vag nicht
aufgehen hey leute wissen karte auf der
autobahn
es ist ein scheiß drauf schaut mal der
da vorne
das auto das von solchen drauf war
perfekt
und 11
bei youtube ist natürlich ein platz den
immer geringer
maske aus
[Applaus]
[Musik]
red bin antwortet und dann noch hier
vorne
[Musik]
red
ihre stärke
unsere
da
genommen
mit der autobahn projekt bevor ich mit
verteilt hatten
in olten worden
von der linken
am montag auf der autobahn so viele der
so viele lkw-fahrer man bücher seiner
polizei betroffen ist aber die kaputte
gekommen ich habe wieder für das team
auf jeden fall
[Musik]
wir haben nichts zu essen und ich habe
einfach lukas tasche genommen seine
tasche in der letzte flug und was
wichtig war heute seinen deutsch gelaunt
statt weil das um den kecken erhöht und
bei der neuesten videos schneiden muss
und diese tasche ist einfach in diesem
wagen den gepäckwagen hier drin frauen
die tasche ist ungefähr 20 er hat von
nicht ganz easy etwa übergewicht ich
ausrasten in der mit kunden tasche weg
ich will aber die klappe halten alle
anderen völlig geschmeckt warum nicht
einmal der wurm drin war
[Musik]
klasse verloren
wo ist der lack hier
gibt's doch gar nicht dort werden jetzt
auf diese insel für fünf tage mit luca
mit meiner freundin mit will alle
zusammen in einem haus aber die richtig
ist wichtig dass die leute vielleicht
fürs zuschauen soweit hier um kalabrien
wir uns überlegt abschicken hier oben
ganz besonders selbstverständlich die
neue folge von wassers geht von meinem
family abdecken lassen